[Music]
i'm extremely driven to build my version
of a deep life filling it with things
that are meaningful and substantive
cutting out the frivolous and harmful
and hedonic pieces and avoiding the
seemingly infinite temptations of
american life that lead to a shallow and
frustrating existence
my fiancee has seemingly little interest
in the arduousness of this lifestyle
preferring ease and comfort as most do i
do not fault her at all for this
preference and i love her above all else
and fully plan on spending my entire
life with her but every time that i try
to convince her to tackle the task of
self-improvement with me it only leads
to arguments and hurt feelings since she
is essentially half of my identity how
do you think i should handle this
should i let it go and try to live half
my life in each camp i find that hard to
swallow since i'm fairly positive that
the comfortable american life basically
smooths out the contours of your soul
nice wording and i have an immensely
difficult time watching that happen to
her no i don't think that's an option so
i guess my final question is how do i
convince her to go on this journey with
me how do i convince her to
forego comfort and decadence especially
when i'm having a hard enough time doing
that myself all right that's a long
question
but i would like to
try to respond to it because
i and i think many people have contended
with this on some level it could be a
significant other it could be a very
close friend it could be
the five people you associate with most
and certainly
drew of dropbox and i and others have
said you are the average of the five
people you associate with most so if you
don't want to get rid of your friends
what do you do if this is an issue in
your
most intimate relationship with a
significant other what do you do and i
can only speak to a few things that i
have tried
because hitting it head-on with some
criticism along the lines of
why aren't you interested in
self-development
is not going to be a crowd pleaser and
is not going to get the
response that you want
so
i'm going to answer this in two stages
the first
is related to an assumption that's
embedded in the first section of this
question
and that was you know should i let it go
and try to live half my life in each
camp i find that hard to swallow
no i don't think that's an option
and
there is a
false dichotomy being created here so
the options that are being presented at
least in the question are live half my
life in each camp so half my life away
from my partner effectively or fully
integrate both of us so we are on the
same program
i'm exaggerating a little bit but that
is a false dichotomy there are other
options and there's a gradient i think
between those two
so first what i've learned is
some things you're just meant to do on
your own
and you don't have to do everything with
your significant other
however if you are going to say
take a week to do
a workshop or
a week for a solo expedition or whatever
it might be
it could just be a week to go to burning
man i mean i'm not saying that
self-development but
you
will benefit from
a relationship that can sustain that so
two people
who are fully capable of being say
self-entertained or self-directed at
least four stints at a time
i think that's important i i do that
with my significant other or just as
easily i could say she does that with me
there are times when we do our own thing
okay
that is component one and then to
the
direct last question how do i convince
her to go on this journey with me
to me convincing implies
speaking and persuading
in conversation and i don't
know that is going to be the most
effective path what i have seen
personally and what i've also seen in
other couples
is the path of least resistance
is often identifying what they already
love
the things they already enjoy
the activities they feel drawn to
and trying to
bend the arc of one of those
one percent
to include what you consider to be
self-development right so
let's just say hypothetically
that your fiance i'm making this up that
she
loves going to yoga
well
you could suggest you could find
a
fantastic
teacher training course
and
if you know you have one to two weeks of
vacation coming up let's just say it's
in a nice location fill in the blank
could be in sedona could be in bali who
knows depending on your budget
and
you could
offer that as an early christmas present
early birthday present or just as a gift
and say that you would like to cover
that
and uh
you thought it could be super fun and
you've been wanting to spend more time
with her
in
her yoga practice so that you can do it
together and
that would be a
non-trivial step in the direction of
self-development i think that would be a
programmatic way
to improve
yoga capabilities
and familiarity with terminology and
also network etc right
so i think we want to meet people where
they are i don't always do a great job
of this i i can be very stubborn and
headstrong and aggressive so
i don't always implement this
in the most delicate or diplomatic way
but i have had success also with this is
just trying to first before you decide
what you're going to convince someone of
or where you want them to go
to meet them where they are do a mental
audit
of the things they love the things that
are easy for them to do
and then try to find a slight variation
on one of those themes that allows them
to step foot in a way that feels good to
them not just to you
towards a path of
self-development i would also say
that
self-awareness
is a very powerful precursor to
self-development so if there are things
that you can do together not just giving
her
homework assignments
that increase self-awareness that could
be somatic self-awareness it could be
getting better at applying things like
the 80 20 principle to career so it
might be a workshop along those lines
anything that
helps to facilitate the habit of turning
the eye inward
and asking questions i think will also
not just lead to self-development but be
self-development in and of itself so
those are a few of my
thoughts on that which is not easy
situation is not always an easy
situation
but i do think there are many options in
between the two polar extremes that you
indicated and i do not think those two
are mutually exclusive i think you can
incorporate
both
you